diamondbacks started tonight the
right-hander luke weaver looking for
some answers here bob he's lost three of
his last four starts yeah luke weaver
has much too good of stuff to have
numbers like this 17 earned runs in his
last 17 innings pitched over four starts
a left-handed hitter their shortstop
tonight he hits this one on the ground
to first
walker gobbles it up he tells weaver
i'll take it to the bag myself he does
aguilar hits one out to david peralta
one pitch out for luke
nice kind of like end of the bat right
there
got him luke waver 97 at the knees
a strikeout to win the first
diamondbacks back home and coming up and
tonight jordan holloway gets his first
major league start he's earned this
opportunity after working 10 scoreless
innings out of the bullpen five times
out four hits three walks ten strikeouts
in his last appearance there's a shot to
right center that's a base hit for pavon
and he'll try for two and he gets by
brinson goes deep and he'll go to third
well now he's going to check it up some
hesitation there rounding second base
and i don't know if he picked up tony
perez chica or not as he was closing in
on second but branson booted that ball
momentarily but it'll be a double no one
two on carson
try the curve ball hits it deep to
center it backs up brinson still backing
up near the wall and it's off the wall
dave and smith had to hold up tony perez
chica going to stop him at third back to
back doubles started off with the
diamondbacks
louis brinson's had a tough defensive
inning after two hitters over rampant
smith's line drive and now gets way too
close to the wall here either you're
going to make a leaping attempt or you
have to back off that wall and play the
carry right and already at the belt
check surrenders to pitch
while four we walk him and they're
loaded for peralta here in this opening
inning and they're loaded with nobody
out for david peralta
right at aguilar they go to second and
they cannot turn to pavin's home with
the diamondbacks grabbed the another rbi
opportunity right here for christian
walker batting fifth tonight
and chopped to third can they turn this
one
what a job of getting out of a huge jam
ball and two strikes on dickerson
leading off the second for the marlins
and he rips a ball right in the right
field corner gonna cut it off pavon
smith
throws to second dickerson is there with
a double
there's the strikeout with a fastball
number two for lee
finally did go to that changeup gets the
strikeout and strands that lead off
double it's one nothing diamondbacks
this guy continues in press eduardo
escobar he's a guy that i played against
on oh one he bounces one on the right
side to the second baseman isan diaz
collects it throws on the first one down
to third
brian anderson
makes the throw across the diamond then
there are two down
[Applause]
lifted out to left
and holloway bounces back nicely with a
one two three inning hollow is out there
swinging the bat and then to the top of
the order in isandia's fly ball get to
center
backing up onto this var show and he's
going to make the catch in front of the
4 13 mark
slap to first christian walkers there
luke weaver has set down five in a row
[Applause]
right at pavon smith that's a quick
inning in the third three outs on seven
pitches luke weaver is feeling it
tonight
and he's two for two tonight knocks it
into center
these two have reached and the
diamondbacks third
and just like in the first inning the
diamondbacks have the bases full and
nobody out here's as drupal cabrera who
walked his first at-bat
line fair down the line and here we go
weaver is home
haven smith on his way home
they're going to stock carson it's a
two-run double for his dribble and it's
three nothing diamondback chance for
christian who hit into a rally killing
inning ending double play to stop the
first
and this one popped up see if wallach
has a chance he's throwing the mask
and he makes the play
two outs in the third and now it's up to
escobar
[Music]
[Applause]
that gets away from wallock here comes
carson it's four nothing relic in his
haste to try to frame a strike
pulled his glove back too quickly and
whiffed on that ball luke weaver has
been almost as good here luke has set
down six in a row and nine of ten
right through the fastball carson kelly
hands on strikeout number four for luke
weber
left center it hangs up there for varsho
she is cruising right now two outs on
four pitches in the fourth
bounced up the middle nick ahmed high
hop for nick
luke weber locked in he set down nine
straight and 12 of the 13 he's faced
back to work luke weaver and brian
anderson first up against him swing out
of miss strike him on another good
change up strikeout number five of the
night for weaver and one out here in the
fifth inning
bounced high in the air ahmed's got a
hurry bare-handed played by nick got it
at first nick ahmed
oh bare hand throw all in one motion
and fairchild the out call at first
here's a close look they're going to put
the headsets on
without it first nick ahmed
two down in the fifth
there's a chopper to short should get
out of it nick's got it fires to first
gets birdie that'll end the inning
chance for christian walker now
christian's had some frustrating at bats
and he lines that into the corner here
comes peralta
another d back double kristen walker
makes it five nothing back to back two
out doubles six doubles in less than
five innings marlins no runs and two
hits luke weaver has been tremendous
here tonight nissan diaz
sends one out to center dalton varshall
was shaded over toward the pool
and that's another one pitch out for
luke weaver that's his sixth one pitch
out he's had one in every inning tonight
now a double play ball throw to first
and he got him weaver picked him off
nice job by luke weaver everybody was
just kind of standing there waiting for
something to happen
out of the corner of his eye he saw
sierra wasn't paying much attention and
just snapped a throw over there to
christian walker for the hour
[Applause]
smith and right
six scoreless for luke weaver does luke
weaver ever have this one has been
sensational six scoreless luke has given
up only three hits
back to the changeup luke weaver and
strikeout number six that's it for luke
weaver 75 pitches
just terrific
right now he's thinking there's story
out on the mound everything that you're
locking in on that tunnel vision i talk
about is in that direction uh-oh aguilar
with a drive the deep left field yeah
that batters eye works two-run homer
putting this one in the books
in the air deep to right field paving
smith back it up near the wall pavement
got it
and the diamondbacks win the ball game
pavon smith takes a home run away
and it's a 5-2 d-max win what a way to
win that one